oh sisters we have been gone
three hundred years out on friday
when you're dead the sanderson sisters
are back
and no this time a virgin didn't
light the candle what happened
a virgin lit the candle so
why are the stars of hocus pocus back in
their iconic costumes
we'll explain
on sunday bette midler shared this shot
standing
side by side with sarah jessica parker
and kathy najimi in front of a blue
screen
backdrop decked out in their witchy
wardrobe
i am beautiful boys would
love me in the pic the trio who starred
as the sanderson sisters in the 1993
comedy
are all smiles as they reprise their
iconic roles together
i am alive
to the game oh you're right you're
always right i don't know it's my
curse that and you too
the caption your three fave witches
sarah jessica parker kathy najimi and me
are returning for one night only on 10
30 at 8 pm
eastern standard time in search of the
sanderson sisters
is the best thing to happen to halloween
since hocus pocus
and reese's pieces then we must find the
book
drew the potion and suck the lies out of
the children of salem before sunrise
the one time only reunion special is
part of a virtual halloween fundraising
event
bet put together called hulaween
benefiting the new york restoration
project and their work in environmental
and social justice
eti caught up with bet at last year's
hulaween gala
and she opened up about her potential
involvement in the hocus pocus sequel
which is in the works at disney plus oh
my goodness me
oh i hope they get to me before i'm of
course
um we want to fly again i hope it's a
big i hope their disney plus is a big
success and i hope we get to do it
because
she is of course one of my favorite
characters i mean she's in the zeitgeist
i have met people who i met like
grown-up people like 40 year olds
50 year olds who say oh i remember that
you hocus pocus i was brought up on it
it's so mortified
because i still look 35. aren't you
boyd's a little old to be
trick-or-treating
we'll be younger in the morning
yeah sure me too that same day
sjp responded to a fan on instagram who
asked about the sequel
writing we have all said yes now we wait
it's just a bunch of hocus pocus